it's been nearly one month since the
emergence of the omicron variant
prompted the biden administration to
restrict travel from eight countries in
southern africa on friday the white
house said it'll be lifting those
restrictions in the next week christina
rafini is at the white house with the
latest christina good morning good
morning and merry christmas a deputy
white house spokesperson said in that
tweet yesterday those restrictions that
travel ban will end on december 31st the
administration says the decision was
recommended by the cdc and that the
travel restriction gave the
administration time to understand the
omicron variant and learn the existing
vaccines are effective against it but
this ban to and from those southern
african nations was controversial
especially in the scientific community
because it was scientists in that region
who first flagged the variant raised the
alarm and the consequence to that
transparency was a travel ban critics
argue that it would in the future harm
global health cooperation and discourage
other nations from coming forward now
south african government also said this
week they believe the country has passed
its peak infection rate and the data
there seems to show this new variant is
highly contagious which we know but not
as severe as other strains so south
africa has now dropped quarantine
restrictions for people who don't have
symptoms because so many of the cases
have been asymptomatic it simply didn't
make sense to only quarantine people who
have tested positive now this is a good
example of countries learning to live
with and try to work with a hopefully
less deadly variant rather than ever
thinking they're going to be able to
wipe out this virus completely michael
christina raffini at the white house
this morning thanks